so welcome to the early access preview
of eldon ring
this area is limgrave or the north part
of it anyway this part has been
sectioned off for the network test but
it's still absolutely massive and i'm
going to show you my favorite route
through this place but yours will be
different
oh yes
tarnished are we
come to the lands between for the elden
ring
of course you have
in the interest of time i'm gonna keep
exploring but i'll continue the npc
dialogue in the background
but i'm afraid you're plum out of luck
you are maidenless
a bit player
fully divorced from the strength of
runes
feel free to go off
and die in a ditch somewhere
so that guy's rude as hell but he ain't
wrong
the game has just started but you should
probably be prepared to be put straight
in the dirt
yeah so if you think you can beat this
guy first time then you're a better
player than i am from software i'm
passing up this opportunity to remind
you what kind of game you're playing
luckily there's ruined church nearby
and you're gonna see why it's ruined in
a minute uh because he can't get in
there but he can
destroy it
parts of the environment are
destructible now and it has a gameplay
purpose as well because you can actually
get up there after he destroys it pretty
cool
you're a tarnished
i can see it
and i can also see
that you're not after my throat
then why not purchase a little something
i am carly
purveyor of fine goods
you know
if you can spare the runes
you should buy yourself a crafting kit
a crafting kit allows you to make basic
items on your own
essential really if you intend to
survive out here for any duration
goodbye
nice to do business
so buying the crafting kit from carly is
highly recommended i'm making some bone
knives now from animal bones that i
found out in the world and that's how
you craft most of the items that will be
familiar to you from dark souls like
fire bombs or prism stones you make
these things from the materials that you
farm out in the world now
i also just equipped a spirit summon
that's another thing i bought from kali
spirit summons are items they use fp to
cast and they summon spirit helpers
you'll see them soon
so right there i performed a guard
counter you do this by blocking an
attack then following up with r2 it does
a lot of damage it does a ton of posture
damage and allows you to get a critical
attack often
highly recommend getting the hang of
that
okay another thing i'm getting the hang
of is the range of carrion piercer one
of the spells that the sorcerer knight
starts with
sorcery's strong it's balanced i like it
you see that statue on the right that's
a statue of marika it's essentially
another type of checkpoint you'll see
them in difficult areas if i was to die
in this area coming up here then i'll
spawn back there instantly
one thing that'll help keep you alive is
stealth you click in the l3 button and
you can sneak around super important for
areas like this because a lot of enemies
here will alert nearby enemies and it
can get out of hand pretty quickly
i'm making my way to this this is a
map fragment
very important the map is just a blur
without it so don't go past without
getting this
so
there's a reason why you're probably
going to want to stealth through this
camp
that
that horn
most enemies here carry it and it alerts
the entire camp to your presence
it's for situations like this i think
that spirit summons were designed
these wolves act as a distraction
allowing me to cleave through enemies
more effectively
i'm doing some pretty good damage here
but
as soon as the wolves die and everyone
turns to face you you kind of realize
you're hopelessly outmatched so
spirit summons can also act as a
distraction for you to like it instead
spirit summons can be very powerful but
remember you can only summon them in
difficult areas
nearby these threads of light guide us
to our third site of lost grace
this is a really important one to visit
greetings
traveller
from beyond the fog
i am melaner
i
offer you an accord
have you heard of the finger maidens
they serve the two fingers
offering guidance
and aid to the tarnished
but you
i am afraid
are maidenless
i can play the role of maiden
turning rune fragments into strength
to aid you in your search for the elden
ring
you need only take me with you
to the foot of the earth tree
then it's settled i bequeath to you this
ring
use it
to traverse great distances
it will summon a spectral steed
named torrent
torrent has chosen you
treat him with respect
now we have our mount torrent who can
take us to some points of interest on
the map i just marked three beacons
we'll head there now
but first mounted combat
so i could go on for a really long time
about its new mechanics and this new
control scheme but
for now can i just say
i love it i think it adds so much depth
to this game
[Music]
that
was so much fun
my god
so make sure you visit melano she also
lets you level up
share them with me
your thoughts
your ambitions
the principles you would follow
this is groveside cave in my opinion it
is
perhaps the most important early game
location that you can visit
the enemies aren't too difficult
but the rewards you get are insane
this is the first reason we're here the
twin blade my weapon of choice in this
network test
you'll see why
[Music]
so that was a jumping attack you can do
jumping r2s and jumping our ones as well
they are very good for breaking enemy
posture and also knocking some enemies
out of the air
you can also do running r1s and running
r2s
so fire grease is one of the better
craftable items i've found it just
requires two things it requires root
resin found near trees and smoldering
butterflies found near wildfires
it's very good against this
bloodborne-esque boss
so you're probably starting to
understand why i like the twin blade its
default weapon art is very strong and it
even stun locks this boss
on the left side of the screen you can
see what weapon art is currently active
the twin blade's default art is called
spinning slash and it's active because
i'm two-handing the weapon if i was to
one-handed and have my shield in the
left hand i would use my shield's weapon
art instead
the beast man drops the viridian amber
medallion which increases your maximum
stamina
but that that in the chest
is why we're here the flask of wondrous
physic
so let's return to a site of grace and
check it out conveniently this beam of
light will appear at the end of every
dungeon allowing you to easily warp to
the surface
hopefully this frees up a little bit of
design space for from software allowing
them to design deeper dungeons that
don't need to loop back around
anyway now we have the ability to mix
wondrous physic at a site of lost grace
here you can bind tears that you find
out in the world to create a potion with
custom effects
now we only have one of these flasks but
you know the best bit
these replenish when you sit at a site
of lost grace so you'll get a ton of use
out of these
here i'm picking up some ruined
fragments these shards of stone are
believed to have once been a part of a
temple in the sky
these hollow enemies digging in the
ground and wandering the lands between
are former nobles according to an item
description they seem to have forgotten
what they were searching for
and now wander aimlessly
eldon ring has this unparalleled
gameplay flow to it where you go
seamlessly from the open world into
these tightly designed dungeons
this second one we're exploring the
stormfoot catacombs
it feels a lot like a chalice dungeon
from bloodborne
these heavy doors require you to go
deeper into the dungeon and unlock them
these dungeons are full of traps and
ambushes you're going to want to keep
your shield up
but
there's some things that your shield
can't really protect you against
the stressful thing is you can hear the
enemy chasing me
but the good thing is i think he gets
burnt to a crisp here
we're in this dungeon specifically to
find one of my favorite ashes of war an
ash of war is essentially a skill that
you can assign to your weapon shield
catalyst or talisman
the twin blade has a really good weapon
art as you can see but
i believe there's one in here that's
even better
and it really suits the sorcerer build
as you can probably expect every dungeon
has a main boss at the end and sometimes
in the middle of it
that last boss looked like it was
inspired by bloodborne but this one is
the nightmare fuel
oh yeah so the flask of wondrous physic
that we mixed does two things first it
restores my health but then it also gets
rid of it because i explode
but the explosion does way more to the
enemy than it does to us
so on the left side of the screen
there's a little symbol looks like a
gravestone
this lets you know that you can summon
help and once again these wolf boys are
a very powerful tool
maybe too powerful i'm not really sure
where i stand on spirit summons yet
bosses clearly have a lot of aoe attacks
now and some bosses do just obliterate
your summons instantly but the fact
remains if you want to be at your most
powerful it is going to almost always be
a good idea to summon your spirits when
you can because they don't cost that
much fp
and they distract the boss long enough
for you to do a ton of damage
this one didn't even die it just dodged
out of the way all the time
i'll be interested to see how from
software decides to balance these
in my opinion they should be careful
about making these too strong but hey
that's the dark souls formula right like
there's no easy mode but there are
in-game ways to make your character more
powerful and there are in-game ways to
find
solutions to difficult encounters and
that is the best way to do an easy mode
so they are a cool addition in that
regard
so anyway what we just got is an ash of
war which you can designate to a weapon
here at the bonfire
they're really interesting ashes of war
add a different weapon art or skill to
your weapon that's what this one is
it summons four homing missiles that
stay with you even on horseback look at
this
this is powerful
maybe too powerful you'll see what i
mean later on in the video
but the other interesting thing about
ashes of war is that they can also be
used to easily assign scaling to your
weapon this ash of war the glint sword
arc for example let me choose between
keeping standard scaling or intelligence
scaling
every ash of war is like this and the
best thing about it is it lets you be
more flexible with your build whereas in
dark souls you had to go to andre and
smith your weapon appropriately
the worst part is that now your scaling
and your ideal scaling might be locked
behind a weapon art you don't want to
use
hitting that turtle gave me one of the
few frame drops i think i've ever seen
while playing this game
i mean you guys can see for yourselves
it looks and plays great on playstation
5.
and roaming the open world man i'm just
the amount of content in here is
staggering so many bosses and places and
npcs ah
you must be the new tarnished
you do well to steer clear of a gill
lake fledgling
a dragon
rooster
and it's as fearsome
as it is majestic
mounted combat is really fun and it's
one of the places where i feel like
sorcery shines quite well
specifically because you can target
their horse and knock them off that way
and then fight them with the advantage
of you being on your horse
but the really fun way to fight is by
doing jousts and you can tell the enemy
ai is coded to engage in jousting with
you
because you can charge attacks the
timing aspect is just as important as
your reflexes and also your creativity
while you fight you know different
weapons have different timings and
different charge attacks and you can use
a variety of spells some of which knock
them off or you can use a bow and arrow
while you ride and even sleep arrows to
put them asleep while they're on
horseback and win that way there's just
a lot of flexibility and creativity in
the ways you prefer to do combat
this is a carriage that has some really
good loot at the back if you can steal
it or take out that huge group of
enemies but for now we're going to go to
the post town remains
and this is where the horse's double
jump really shines
sometimes it's surprisingly useful to
get on top of a tall structure so that
you can see everything that's below you
this lets us see the remains of the town
and it reveals that
there is a staircase in a little room
that cannot be accessed unless you jump
that direction or you jump over these
fences
if you were on foot you might never have
found it
pumpkin head he's aptly named and his
head is actually completely immune to
damage which can definitely screw you
over depending on the weapons you're
using
he also makes short work of our summons
so you'll see that summons aren't always
super useful
one thing it took me a while to remember
is that you know like dark souls shields
are very
very effective rolling through
everything might get you killed more
often than not interestingly though a
lot of bosses now inflict a bleed effect
i've noticed so you can't just rely on
hiding behind your shield all the time
or that bleed effect is going to get out
of control
another advantage of two-handing weapons
i found is that it deals significantly
more posture damage
posture is now this weird blend of dark
souls and secure where it's this
invisible meter that you build up
like in dark souls i guess but unlike
dark souls it builds up on them
regardless of whether they're blocking
so for example any boss that you're
hitting is probably taking posture
damage and depending on the weapon
you're using and the nature of the
attacks you're doing you might open them
up to a critical attack
it doesn't happen against this boss but
it's definitely worth keeping in mind
tarnished are we
no wonder you should turn up here
this is sorceress celine an nbc who
appears here in the network test but i
guess it's unlikely she'll be here in
the full game she sells a few decent
sorceries but the real reason we're here
is for that lore and she tells you some
good stuff about glenstone sorceries and
how it differs from sorcery in the souls
games our art draws upon the powers
embedded in glindstone
but what is the nature of such power
glimstone is the amber of the cosmos
golden amber contains the remnants of
ancient life
and houses its vitality
while glimstone contains residual life
and thus
the vitality of the stars it should not
be forgotten
that glimstone sorcery is the study of
the stars and the life therein
while roaming this way you might come
across the black knight guarding the
bridge he only appears here at night
time
he's also very difficult so we'll
continue but we have time to look at
this
it's a sort of dung beetle a sparkling
one that gives items and they can be
found all across the lands between
oi
you you there
could you help us out
make sure you visit that grove of trees
when you finally play this game
for us now though it's time to breach
the storm gate and
head towards stormvale castle
stormville castle is the first legacy
dungeon in eldon ring it blocks your
access to the next section of the open
world and it's sort of like a
traditional dark souls dungeon in the
sense that it's this big tightly
designed space where you can't use your
horse
breaking through here can be very
difficult if you take the time to fight
and even if you take the time to loot it
can quickly become a really epic chase
sequence
there are so many curiosities and points
of interest hidden around the place
you'll miss a lot if you just follow the
main path
this isn't really an open world like
ghost of tsushima or the witcher or
skyrim where it's a lot of really vast
distance for the sake of it feeling vast
and making the world feel huge
so far i'm impressed with how densely
populated the area is with intriguing
things like
these
one-eyed snake statues and the evergell
that they got
foolishly i think i forgot to sit at a
grace before i fought bloodhound knight
daryl and i'm low on crimson tears and
i'm very low on fp and fp is kind of
what i'm relying on to do most of my
damage with since i haven't taken the
time to upgrade my weapon
[Applause]
interestingly this is a boss fight where
you can't use spirit summons so there
are going to be boss fights where you
can't use that as a crutch
not that i could summon them anyway with
no fp
[Music]
feeling a bit desperate i decide to play
this really really defensively seeing as
i have basically no health left but
he is doing only physical damage
the thing i forget is that he's also
doing bleeding damage
of course when you die your runes are
left behind at your point of death they
even show up on the compass which helps
you to find your way back to them ours
are in the ever jail with the bloodhound
i wonder why he's locked away in here
luckily we can choose to respawn at a
statue of marika
at first i thought i would be against
these but when you realize how vast the
open world is and how tedious it would
be to ride back to everything
they are a nice convenience to have
sometimes
this time we go in with full fp
and
i can show you why glintstone arch is
such a good weapon art
yeah
so
weapon arts or skills or ashes of war
whatever you call them they're powerful
especially the magical ones and
especially when you consider that they
get more powerful when you upgrade your
weapon
and i haven't upgraded my weapon yet you
can get weapons to plus three in this
beta weapon arts need to be powerful if
they're going to be used by players i
feel like a lot of the weapon arts in
dark souls 3 and secure just weren't
used because they weren't powerful
it's a difficult line for from software
to walk if i had to give one
recommendation it's that weapon arts
should cost a lot more fp
that way they're still powerful and
people will use them but there is a
drawback
right now why would i use sorcery or
faith if a weapon art can do the same
thing and weapon art doesn't even
require me to invest stats into it
necessarily
but i'm curious to hear what you guys
think
according to the elden ring twitter long
ago in the time before the shattering
wolves dared not roam the lands between
now
they're everywhere apparently appearing
out of gusts of wind
there is a lot of law in the network
test but the thing is i think enemy
drops have been tweaked so that they
don't drop you know their related items
and weapons and equipment so there is a
lot of law in the network test in the
items but getting law for a specific
enemy has proven quite difficult
you might have noticed now sitting at
this grace there's a new option that
says about grace
with this you can ask melana a little
bit more about grace's and sometimes a
little bit more about herself
me
i'm searching
for my purpose
given to me by my mother inside the
urgery
long ago
for the reason that i yet live
burned
and bodyless
there is something for which i must
apologize
i've acted the finger maiden
yet can offer no guidance
i am no maiden
my purpose
was long ago
lost we're nearing the end of eldon
ring's first open world and the start of
its legacy dungeon marking this
transition is our first mandatory boss
the difficulty of this boss is what
drove me to create such a powerful
character this time
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
let it be market the fell
margaret the fell is tough he has a lot
of attacks that come out at a moment's
notice and a lot of gap closers that can
catch you while you're trying to heal
when i finally beat him for the first
time it was with a way weaker greatsword
build and no summons the only way i
could manage it was by delaying his
second phase as much as possible and
making sure i broke his posture within
it have a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
i shall remember thee
tarnished
smoldering with thy meager flame
cower in fear
of the night
the hands of the fell omen shall brook
thee no quarter
that's the end of this first preview but
there's a lot more elton ring content to
come so subscribe for that but beyond
that there's a lot more content in this
test that we weren't allowed to access
so
that's something to get truly excited
about thank you from software and namco
for helping me get access to this and
thank you for watching